so i think it's
not going to be that you could just
throw in this one enzyme and it's going
to fix everything however there are
compounds that are stimulatory
for repair processes and maybe these
might actually work
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video i had
the great pleasure of speaking with
matthew youssef a research assistant
professor at the university of minnesota
who's made many great contributions to
the research field of cellulosin essence
dna damage and aging
i hope you enjoy our conversation
so hi matt thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the chicky science
show
yeah thanks for having me i'm really
excited about this awesome so i thought
i would start by talking about probably
one of your most cited publications
which is about the compound physician or
physician or whatever you'd love to
pronounce it um where you describe its
action as a semi-therapeutic and so that
covers the topic of cellular senescence
which i'm sure my viewers are somewhat
familiar with but maybe a smaller
introduction would be helpful i was just
wondering if you could provide some like
background to this work like why were
you looking at visiting and
what what what exactly were you looking
at in the paper
so once again just
our la the lab that i'm in really
focuses on cellular senescence analytics
and cellular senescence is uh sulfate uh
whereby cells are
cellulocess is induced by stress uh
cells basically undergo the sulfate or
they're no longer able to proliferate
even if you give them mitogenic stimuli
so you can dump in all the nutrients and
growth factors that you want they're not
going to
proliferate grow and divide anymore
however they're metabolically active and
they can produce some pretty nasty stuff
so inflammatory chemokines and cytokines
and that's known as the senescence
associated secretory phenotype
which can then sort of act both
proximately and distally to
create inflammation drive secondary
senescence sort of disrupt tissue
homeostasis and drive aging where it
ultimately shortens uh healthspan
disease-free survival or lifespan
and just to write as i joined laura's
lab
um the first cinelytics paper came out
where it used the synalitic combination
of the satin and corsetin
and it showed really promising effects
and it's gone on to launch a number of
clinical trials
um and as we get into making second and
third generations analytics we want to
make more effective drugs but also
safer drugs so desatinib is a
chemotherapeutic tyrosine kinase
inhibitor that has its own sort of known
side effects
and so we went and looked at uh analogs
of percentage of polyphenol flavonoid
and we screened other flavonoids to see
if they were as potent as a crescent or
more potent
and what we came up with was we found
faceting was using an in vitro screening
model for
uh
eradication of senescent cells
similarly we did this both in a human
and a mouse cell line and then from
there moved into some mouse studies
where we were able to see uh
using either naturally aged mice or a
mouse model of accelerated aging that's
sort of the backbone of our lab we saw
significant reductions in senescent cell
burden
and if we did a late life intervention
with really old mice where they sort of
at the human equivalent of about 65
years of age and you start them on a
diet with the satin where it's
compounded into the chow
it extended lifespan and it reduced
pathology as well as senescent cell
burden in them
and so that's really
kind of
where we've started with that and now
we're sort of using
the satin and a number of other things
where we had another paper that had come
out
uh showing that we use facetin in a
mouse model of normal microbial
experience so most typically
everybody that's doing mouse model work
keeps their mice in very pristine
conditions uh specific pathogen free
and really we want to better mimic
what's going on in the human environment
where we're always exposed to pathogens
and we're very susceptible as we get
older to sepsis and other infections
um and that's not always seen when you
have a really clean environment where
you're housing old mice so we would
actually either co-house our mice with
pet shop mice or you would uh house them
in a cage with fomite bedding from this
pet shop mice
and we used a uh what we found was the
agent that was most lethal to them in
the fomite bedding or in the pet shop
mouse was mouse hepatitis virus a beta
coronavirus
and typically we had come up with this
hypothesis this rheostatic model where
infection and will drive inflammation
but because these older mice had such a
higher sness and cell burden they were
already pre-primed for senescence and so
you get this hyper activation of sass
and inflammation and that can drive
mortality and decrease survival and so
what we did was we either tried
pre-treatment with faceting or in a
therapeutic study we would induce
infection or co-housing or fomite
bedding and then give them facet and
what we saw was a reduction in senescent
cell burden as well as a significant
increase in survival
well no that's i didn't know that that's
really interesting uh results and so
like you've mentioned how you give it to
the mice but how exactly are the mice
getting the first things obviously like
um in terms of bioavailability how okay
is that
resolved and like in terms of like
applying it to human clinical trials
like how do you like what do you think
would be the most effective like
strategy to employ uh facilities
so in in the
the mouse coronavirus trials that was
given typically
um one of two ways they usually get
boluses through oral gabage
and then on non-gavaging days you would
give it in the chow originally in the
paper with the late life intervention it
was always compounded in the child it's
the easiest way to give it to them it's
the least stressful on an animal
um and
i think in the human clinical trials
with the sudden
uh they are
given it orally so
okay and so one of my questions about
foster as well was like obviously as
being like the kind of biochemist that i
am i really want to know like the
mechanism of action or festen and so is
there any idea as to how it's working
yet
i i think facetime is one of those
compounds that falls into the category
of dirty drugs it's probably doing a ton
of different things
um
you know there's papers out there that
say it stimulates glutathione production
you know it's involved in inhibiting a
certain
molecular pathway some people think it's
acting through mtor
i think it's
i think we would have to sort of sit
down with the individual compounds that
can act on those same pathways and see
can we recapitulate the effects of facet
and sort of see
which one of those molecular targets is
actually most important to sort of the
center therapeutic effects of satin but
it definitely doesn't fit the classical
pharma model of one drug one target
yeah me for sure and so like obviously
one of the reasons you've mentioned why
you studied festive was to find like an
alternative to the combination of
disaster and question but a study that
came out the end of last year identified
a new like cenolitic agent in grapeseed
extracts and protein iodine c1 so i mean
like how do you think that compares to
festertin i don't know if you've seen
this study but um
and do you think that foster may be like
targeting a specific like subtype of
senescent cells or like uh could you exp
elaborate on that
yeah so i i saw that study it's really
promising it's cool that you know we're
we're seeing more analytics coming out
you know hopefully we're we're making
better ones you know i love it if
there's something better than faceting
you know it means it has more potency
and it's going to help more people out i
think the other thing is
not we have to think about that
senescent cells they have these things
called scaps or senescent cell uh
anti-apoptotic pathways and these scaps
are these pathways that are up regulated
are probably going to be in some context
cell type or tissue
specific and
we've seen before that certain analytics
have more of a potent effect in certain
cell types
so there is going to be cell type
specificity to the effect of some of
these center therapeutics and
you know going forward there may be a
synolitic that works better in the
kidney than it does in the knee joint
for osteoarthritis
so i think that's where the field has to
go we have to learn a lot more about
senescent cells and there is a really
interesting grant mechanism that came
out that was sponsored by the nih in the
u.s and
it's having the senescence tissue
mapping centers or what's called sendnet
and so i think there was originally
supposed to be six of them but there's
now eight of these tissue mapping
centers um university of minnesota being
one of them
and they're mapping uh senescent cells
and particular tissues in healthy aging
and so i believe the u54 tissue mapping
center at the university of minnesota is
tasked with liver and adipose tissue
someone another institution has brain
somebody has lung kidney
and similarly there's going to be the
mouse version of this that i think
everybody was submitting grants for they
were due on tuesday
um and so they'll be matching up to
those tissues as well as doing others
and so it's a great way to sort of see
what we get
in the human side and the mouth side
obviously human being the much more
relevant but mice we have so many tools
and so many good models of senescence
and really you're just trying to build
um not just a 3d map of senescence so
say in a liver is it a senescent
hepatocyte is it a macrophage is it an
endothelial cell
um
are they senescent what markers are they
expressing and then what about the cells
around them so you're not only creating
a 3d map but a 4d map because you're
looking with time
that'd be really cool to get that data
um yeah so these are five-year
initiatives so i think at the end of the
five years we're gonna know way more
than we know right now
yeah that'd be really cool um yeah
because as you say there's
senescent cells are very heterogeneous
it depends um on their location and also
like how they become senescent in the
first place and so uh just keeping with
cellulitis a little bit more like what
are your thoughts on the cult oh like um
hit and run strategy approach
um
i think the hit and run strategy
approaches you know that to me is
it's the smart way to do it if we
basically say we have a drug that
eradicates nests and cells if it's you
know cleared out the bulk majority of
the burden
you shouldn't have to be taking it
constantly
um until you sort of reach another
critical mass of senescent cells
um now they may have beneficial effects
you know say like a set if it is a
glutathione stimulator it could have
positive effects for continuous uh
treatment
and you know that's some of what we've
done with these uh late
late life intervention studies is we
just kept them on the channel um because
we don't know the dosing regimen yet i
think everybody would agree in this
analytics field we don't know you know
truly the frequency the dose everything
per person we're still sort of working
that out
um but ideally we would be doing hit and
run
um and it's probably a way that if you
had a synolytic that
maybe had some side effects for
everything you're sort of de-risking it
minimizing it by only giving it
intermittently
yes okay that's a really good point and
so obviously um in terms of like senior
therapeutic strategies said analytics is
kind of like just like one branch of the
the tree of creatures and like the two
other methods are semimorphics and kind
of activation of the immune surveillance
so the immune cells that could maybe
clear the senescent cells and so that
kind of leads me on to a paper that you
published last year
about advancing um immune system aging
and how that seemed to lead to an
increase in senescent cells so could you
elaborate on that story
yeah i think the only thing i want to
say about that point that you brought up
is i think cena therapeutics is the big
umbrella in which everything sort of
rests underneath you have synalytics
which actively and selectively kill
senescent cells you have cinemorphics
which are drugs that don't kill
senescent cells but maybe they suppress
that senescent phenotype so they're
reducing the amount of sass
and then you're right you do have drugs
that are probably immune stimulatory
that basically bring in uh
immunosurveillance and the eradication
of senescent cells that would typically
occur like in a young and healthy
individual
um and and you know that's really
important that basically uh there's this
concept called immunosine essence which
is different than say senescence and
immune cells immunosine essence is the
progressive
and age-related decline in immune
function it's marked by a number of
things um
dynamic atrophy reduced
t cell response stem cell exhaustion
markers of increased markers of immune
exhaustion
um
and so what we wanted to do is
investigate the importance of the immune
system and senescence in the immune
system on the rest of the organism and
really
by and large before this what we've done
in laura's lab was we've worked with
systemic models of senescence where we
knocked out a dna repair gene here cc1
throughout the mouse and we saw a
significant increase in incessance
throughout the entire mouse
that's great but if you want to study
segmental aging or i want to see what
happens in the spleen
and then what the spleen does to the
rest of the body the cell non-autonomous
effects that model's not so great so we
made tissue specific knockouts of ercc
one using the lox p crease system which
is a really nice system that everybody
uses to delete genes in a sort of
temporal spatial manner
and so we deleted ercc1 and
hematopoietic stem cells
using
the creamer combination driven by the
the vav promoter
and so we in effect knocked out ercc one
from hematopoietic cells um and
what we saw was that when the mice are
young there's no increase in senescence
in the lymphoid organs but as they get
older as they get to about that five or
six months stage we start to see
senescence and dysfunction there and it
really hyper elevates as the mice get
older so that the level of senescence in
a spleen by about a little less than a
year looks like that and a two two and a
half year old mouse
um similarly if you can measure uh
immune function in those mice like you
can do foot pad swelling where you
sensitize them to an antigen and then
look for foot pad swelling when you sort
of get that antigen back
similar to how you would do a tb test
where you're looking for the mark on
your arm
um
we saw significant reductions in that
mouse model
and those that reduction was comparable
too but didn't exceed the level that was
observed in an old mouse
um and going back to your point of
immune surveillance
we also looked at nk cell cytotoxicity
so nk cells t cells macrophages are all
thought to aid and senescent cell
removal
um
and some of the work that's been done by
valerie krzynovsky's lab has really
shown that nk cells can play a prominent
role in this um
and so falling upon that line and sort
of using his work as inspiration um i
measured nk cell cytotoxicity from these
immunosines mice and saw a significant
reduction in their cytotoxicity showing
that you know
there could be impairments in the
clearance of senescence cells
um that occur through the increased
endogenous dna damage which drives
senescence
in the immune compartment
yeah that's true i thought study when i
read it last year was so interesting and
it kind of raises the idea of like maybe
a vicious cycle that obviously you age
the immune system and then that can also
mean that you reduce the clearance of
some cells which then could cause more
aging and yeah i think that's really
fascinating
yeah i i sort of use the analogy that
the immune system is making a bunch of
trash
through through increased sas but then
the immune system itself is is tasked
with clearing the trash out and it's not
even doing a good job at that so the
whole house is just filling up with
rubbish
i think you've just reminded me this is
a very neat reference to monsters inc
where there's like one of them once it
says cleaning up the floor but it's a
snail so it's also like creating more
like slime behind it um but that's
besides the point um one thing that i
found very interesting with that your
paper is that as you um i think you've
already mentioned that as you like
reduce the function of the immune cells
you also saw senescent cells increase in
different organs that one's immune
system organs
and i believe you saw like in particular
increase in senescent cells and like the
liver and the lung but maybe not so much
in the skin and so i was just wondering
if maybe this data could infer where i
mean senescence surveillance is more
important
so i think i think you could see you
could infer some of that i think that
it's
the caveat to it i should
uh sort of work backwards and say that
uh we were looking for cell
non-autonomous effects and what we saw
with senescence occurring in the
non-lymphoid compartments the solid
organs and the first question there is
well is it just resonant immune cells in
those tissues that are senescent and it
turned out not to be it turned out to be
bona fide parenchymal senescence because
we did co-staining in c2 hybridization
with one of our collaborators at the
mayo clinic
um and so it really is senescence
occurring in those uh non-lymphoid
organs we're seeing the resulting tissue
dysfunction so increased markers of
liver dysfunction that are observed in
the blood we saw increased protein nuri
in the kidney indicating kidney
dysfunction
um
now as far as going back where where the
tissues had the highest level of
senescence versus
lower ones
i think some of that is also seen
naturally when we looked at naturally
age mice and systemic we age uh
systemically aged accelerated aging mice
um
where like the aorta for instance when
we looked at naturally aging and
uh the accelerated aging models had the
highest sort of ratio of senescence in
the old mice compared to the young mice
um and that just happened to sort of
bear play now i don't know if that's
just those tissues have more of a
propensity for senescence
um they're more sensitive to it and they
have much more of a dynamic range that's
there
or does amino surveillance also come
into play and that definitely could be
the case i think that's going to take
a lot more study
yeah for sure because like i guess yeah
so do you think that certain organs are
more accessible to the immune system and
so immune surveillance is more likely in
those organs
i definitely think so i think you know
where the
where the immune system can go say
you know would you take something like
the liver which is rich in immune cells
versus say an immune privilege organ
like the eye
you know i think that that would be a
cool sort of study to look at there and
see you know the effects of
uh defective or immunosine essence mouse
model what are the effects on the eye
unfortunately the vab model doesn't work
so great because there is leakiness in
the eye of the mice
so we would also be deleting the uh the
target gene there too so it really kind
of muddies the water
yeah that's yeah i yeah i think these
questions are really interesting and
hopefully yeah we can define it like
experimental methods to try and address
them um but like just one yeah the other
thing that you did in that paper was you
then treated the mice with rapamycin i
believe and yeah could you explain that
part
yeah so uh rapamycin basically compound
found produced what by the bacteria on
the island of rapa nui or easter island
uh it's been shown uh i think for about
13 years ago was shown to increase
lifespan in mice as part of the nih
intervention testing program
some other people had shown it was
immune stimulatory and mice and
joan manick when she originally starting
at novartis and at restore bio had
papers out showing that it was immune
stimulatory in elderly individuals
where they tested them with a short
course of rapamycin treatment and then
looked at influenza
vaccination tighter levels and saw a 20
increase which is massive considering
how poor vaccination efficacy is in the
elderly i think they also saw reduced
pd-1 a marker of immune immune
dysfunction and exhaustion
on t cells as well so sort of drawing
upon inspiration from that i wanted to
see you know could we use the mouse
model possibly as a vaccination model
um or is it would rapamycin just be
immune stimulatory could it correct some
of the deficits
and you know giving the mice six weeks
of rapamycin before letting them sort of
wash out
and then performing some of the analysis
of immune function we did see a partial
correction of deficits um it wasn't a
full restoration but it definitely made
things better
it reduced systemic senescence reduce
the circulating sass factors
and help to improve some of the
lymphopenia that we observed in the
mutant model
okay that's really interesting and so um
like rapid mice and i believe because of
the way and it inhibits mtor and m2
being involved in the task also
seems to maybe be acting as a
stenomorphic but like would you agree
with that
i would i would definitely call uh
rapamycin cenomorphic at least so yeah
i say i think yeah the other thing so
we've spoken a lot about i guess like
immune surveillance and analytics but in
terms of the sending morphs like
sometimes i hear it described as like
complete blunting of the sass but i
guess i i think the better way to kind
of describe it is there's like good and
bad secretory uh
components of the task and so i guess
steady morphics in theory would be a way
of trying more to suppress like the bad
aspects as opposed to the good aspects
i i think that's right where there you
know there are positive aspects of sas
you know and there's positive aspects of
snes
you know senescence is incredibly
important for developmental biology
where
you needed a cell
population for development then you need
to shut it off and get rid of it
and the way it gets rid of it is by
producing the sas to come in and
eradicate those cells
similarly it's important for wound
healing too to you know
ultimately prevent excessive fibrosis in
a young healthy system now as we get
older we have that sterile increase in
inflammation and what's known as
inflammation
um
so i think that yeah the uh the
cenomorphics you know it depends
could you i know i think thomas one's
nikki's lab has shown that maybe aspirin
and other nsaids could even be
cinemorphic so i guess it depends upon
the degree of activity and like
everything else there's always a
therapeutic window
where you have you know a low dose it's
not really that effective you have that
nice sort of sweet spot and above it you
have you know toxicity or unintended
off-target effects
yeah i say kind of segwaying a little
bit um one topic that i also think is
kind of important in the fields um is
like what is the main inducer of
senescence in vivo and i know that
you've done a lot of work with looking
at dna damage and so i was interested to
hear your thoughts on yeah what you
think the answer might be
so my background's on dna repair so i'm
partially biased um
i think i would take a beating from
everybody if i said dna damage is the
driver of aging so i will be uh
cautious and say it is a driver
of aging it's you know genomic
instability is one of those hallmarks of
aging where you have all of them
and you know there's so much interplay
between them dna damage can drive
senescence can bring in inflammation
which can in turn drive dna damage
so everything's interconnected there's
you know forward feedback cycles
um everything but what we do know is
that we've looked um
laura before i got to the lab and
profile tissues for certain dna damage
types in certain lesions
one of them being oxidative lesions
these cycloperian adducts
and uh what you saw in certain tissues
they increased with age but certain ones
they didn't like they increased in the
liver and the kidney but not say in the
brain or the heart and it could be that
certain tissues have this threshold for
dna damage where if it reaches a
threshold now there's stress
and then they can invoke cellular
senescence whereas that second threshold
in certain tissues like the brain may be
very low where you have stress and then
you just have apoptosis
and there's very little room for
senescence there in certain cell types
i'm sure you know it's organ dependent
but it's also cell type dependent and
that may be why we didn't see
those increased lesions in uh certain
organs is because those shell those
cells were just driven to apoptosis
yeah or other cell death mechanisms i
should say
so kind of
moving on beyond what i said before
about
dna damage in tissues we've also learned
a lot from
in aging from individuals that were
treated with cancer where
chemotherapeutics we know in some cases
can prematurely drive frailty
so that somebody a pediatric cancer
survivor
you know by the time they hit their
early 30s if they've experienced
multiple rounds of chemotherapeutics
they could end up looking like a 60 year
old you know based upon frailty scores
we also have these
dna repair disorders
where they have features of aging
whether it be systemic or
tissue related and some of them just it
gets further complicated by them
displaying mosaicism as well but um
the mouse model that we work on the ercc
one model is based off of xfe progeria
which was the sentinel patient had a
mutation and xpf the binding partner of
the ercc one and it's basically a
molecular pair of scissors
that's used to clip out damaged dna or
just
overhangs that need to be trimmed away
and if you think about it like xpf is
the blade of the scissor and the rcc one
is the handle which binds onto the dna
um so there's a lot that we've learned
from the rare disease patient space as
well as cancer survivors and the effects
of dna damage on aging as well that's
really interesting and so like one thing
i think is worth mentioning is like when
i think about dna damage there's kind of
like two
main categories there's like exogenous
damage mechanisms and endogenous damage
and like so could you elaborate on like
what are the major differences between
them and how which one do you think is
more likely to be causing aging in the
body
yeah so uh
exogenous sort of occurring outside the
body endor just occurring inside of it
exogenous would be you go out in the sun
for the entire day and the next day
you're as red as a lobster because
you've incurred so much uv photo damage
from being outside
and
there's a rare disease group that we
work with called zeroderma pigmentosum
um or xp
and so these patients have mutations in
the nucleotide excision repair of which
grcc1 xpf plays a role in um that are
used to remove uh photo lesions as well
as bulky dna addicts so things that
occur like bpd addicts that occur from
cigarette smoking
um
an endogenous uh could occur from
things such as aidoxo guanine that occur
from oxidative damage as that arises
from normal metabolic processes
um obviously
uh the more dysfunction you have going
on say as you get older the more
mitochondrial dysfunction the more
reactive oxygen species leak you're
going to have which can in turn increase
more of these oxidative dna
lesions but just typically i think the
estimates are per cell per day
you have 50 000 dna damage events
so there's already this baseline that's
going on in every single cell per day
and obviously there's variability
between the different cells in your body
where you know oxidative dna damage may
be more common in the liver say bone
where normoxy in a bone is zero percent
i see and so like
in terms of the fact that you'll see
there's like endogenous repair
mechanisms within our cells do you think
it's possible that we could like try and
activate those to try and alleviate some
of the like increased damage that we
seem to see with aging
yeah and for the most part you know
obviously
loss of these repair mechanisms is
pretty deleterious um
not really most of these repair
mechanisms you can't just add back one
factor
and it or an excess of one factor and it
fixes everything um i know people are
working with cert six and cert six is
involved in a number of different
uh repair pathways as well as other
processes it's got a couple of different
enzymatic functions
um
so i think it's
not going to be that you could just
throw in this one enzyme and it's going
to fix everything however there are
compounds that are stimulatory
for repair processes and maybe these
might actually work
um so that may be a possible
therapeutic
i see and so besides obviously dna
damage what other like major factors do
you think are causing aging
um so i've always gotten interested in
oxidative stress that was kind of one of
the first projects i worked on when i
joined laura's lab and what we saw is
that as you get older um your body is
producing more reactive oxygen species
um you're also
simultaneously you're losing your
antioxidant buffering capacity so
enzymatically you know catalase activity
is down as well as the expression of
some of these antioxidants so
it really creates the vicious cycle so
that's kind of one of the other things
i've been interested in and now more and
more looking at
the role of the immune system in
senescence both driving it and from a
surveillance standpoint
so are you are you able to like
elaborate a bit more on like your
current research project
yeah um
so moving beyond that uh amino
senescence mouse model we kind of wanted
to look at well the different immune
cell populations you know
does it take all of them in concert
having dysfunction driven by deletion of
ercc one and increase in essence cell
burden to really drive organismal aging
or is one cell type more prominent than
the other so we're trying to make
different immune cell type knockout so a
b cell will knock out a macrophage
knockout and going from there um
there was a preprint out by george
grindis's lab that showed
uh
cx3cr1 cream ice where they deleted ercc
one so it can delete and
uh
tissue resonant macrophages as well as
microglia the mice had cerebral atrophy
i don't know that they've done any
lifespan analysis but there it does seem
to be
some systemic effects going on too so i
think this is going to be a pretty
uh promising thing to look at and say if
you find something in a t cell
then you've really got to stratify down
even further well what about a cd4 t
cell a cd8 an effector t cell
regulatory t cells
you know
somebody can make an entire career often
so
no i agree the immune immunology is a
very it was complicated and yeah i guess
it's hard to
to understand the different like
categories of different immune cells and
understand like the receptors and how
they interact so i guess that was i
guess another interest of mine is like
how are immune cells recognizing
senescent cells is it purely based on
something that they're secreting or like
what are your thoughts on that
sure well i think there was the paper
that came out from judy campisi's lab
with what uh
nk
d2g
which is a signal for nk cells and to
sort of eat things or engulf things i
believe i'm
wrong somebody correct me but uh i'm
only on here with you right now so we'll
go with it um and what the senescent
cells can do as part of the sas they can
produce those or express those matrix
metalloprotease enzymes which could then
cleave that marker off the
outside of the cell
and i think it was done through mmp
three six or nine
um
and so you're sort of losing that signal
that allows them to sort of be eaten
and degraded
um so that that's part of it is you know
the cell surface that things are
decorating themselves with to track
the immune cells um they're sort of
trying to clip them off
you know don't find me but then also as
you get older those immune cells just
aren't doing their job as well either
yeah and it also just reminds me of
another interesting avenue of like
trying to clear semester cells which is
um like the car t cells that are like
designed to close nested cells by
targeting like
uh proteins are only expressed on the
surface of semester cells and we'll see
like the healthy cells as like a way of
being more specific than using like
different cellulitic drugs
so i think they're talking about
specifically the work that was done by
scott lowe's lab and um yeah and i think
right now we're hampered by that that
there's not really a great specific
senescent cell surface marker
but you could get around that in some
cases by having car t cells that have
low affinity right so if you have this
marker that's really high on cent cells
but it's also found on other cells you
would use a car t that has a low
affinity antibody
so it's really only latching on to
senescence cells and eradicating them
and so uh that could be a technique for
that so it all depends upon the target
target discrimination and then with car
t you can play with antibody affinity as
well
that's a great yeah that's a good point
you i didn't think of that that's yeah
so i think the semester field is really
exciting obviously i think we're both
buyers because they're both in the
fields but um i think there's lots of um
different approaches and there's so many
questions like still left to address
um okay i agree with you that we're
biased i think there's so much cool
stuff that's going on the aging space
and that you're really cool if you work
in it but you're cool if you work on
senescence
even cooler yeah
yeah um and so you're speaking a lot
about senescence now but um what other
areas of the aging fields are like kind
of uh i
are of interest to you
um so really i i'm heavily into
senescence and dna damage
uh the other thing that i've sort of
gotten into
over the last five or six years working
in laura's labs actually outreach
um so we have been doing these workshops
uh for underrepresented groups to bring
them into the aging go to bring the
aging field to them not only giving them
didactic lectures from experts in the
field
um also giving them some laboratory
experience really an exposure
um and then going from there to help
sort of get them and keep them in the
pipeline so i've been working on that
and more and more helping to do some
mentorship in the lab and uh
you know because i can only do so much
at the bench but if you can take and
train and you know uh
inspire people and hopefully you know
you've enabled and empowered them they
can drive the community so much further
than i can ever do on my own and that's
kind of what i've been trying to work on
and recently i've been uh
i've sort of taken on the role as the
gero science junior uh
uh junior trainee reviewer sort of the
chief reviewer
to get
trainees for the american aging
association sort of at that senior
graduate student and postdoc level get
them into the pipeline and get them
starting to review papers
um as they're really starting to write
their own or they have been writing
their own to you know maybe that helps
them increase the quality of their paper
maybe it just helps them to become a
better reviewer
i'm satisfied with that
that sounds pretty yeah that's really
important work um and so i mean what
kind of advice would you give to people
who are like either a interested in the
fields or like
i guess researchers like myself
just start
building a network and emailing people
even if you think you have no business
talking to them just send them an email
you know hey i saw your paper i really
liked it like i really liked your uh
review article i thought it was great i
think uh everybody emphasizes p16 and
p21 i thought your
your review article did a great job of
reminding everybody about p53 and you
know the non-stressed state the acute
state and really the chronic state and
you know things that we need to think
about i think it's sort of
under thought of
thank you
yeah so i think it's just
things like that just sort of meeting if
you can get to a meeting meet as many
people as you can um even now we've gone
so virtual just start emailing people
can i have an informational interview
you know what do you do what's your day
like what projects you have going on you
know what advice do you have
and most people they can carve out 20
minutes to chat with you
yeah no i completely agree i think as
you say yeah i know as well you're very
um prevalent on twitter and i think
again that's something i try to like
advise people interested in science to
do because it's a great way to just see
like the current research papers
yeah
i would think that you and i probably
just by being on twitter probably have
immediate access to those papers before
we ever would have seen them on pubmed
or through other searches so i i feel
like
compared to other people in the lab i'm
a couple of days to a week ahead of them
on paper
yeah yeah exactly i mean that's yeah one
of the main reasons why yeah i use it um
and given speaking of like recent
announcements um
there was the announcements of
outsourced labs
today um and so i guess one from that
like what are your just general thoughts
about the different companies that are
now rising in the field and i guess your
thoughts on tele-love reprogramming
i think cellular reprogramming is really
interesting um
i think it's you know once again it's
gene therapy so there's an uphill
sort of struggle with it i mean can we
find
small molecules or biologicals that
mimic the biological benefit of
epigenetic reprogram i think that's
really how you democratize the science
and the therapeutics
um you know can you can we basically do
that to
give cellular reprogramming to the
developing world so that it's not just a
first world treatment
you know that it could be used in a
rural clinic somewhere um
i think now is probably the best time to
ever get into the longevity space as far
as
uh
you know from an academic standpoint as
well as even from a commercial
standpoint i'm also sort of looking to
get into that uh
you know is there anything that i can do
to help to commercialize some of the
discoveries that we've made in the lab
and so i've recently done i'm currently
doing the on-deck longevity biotech
fellowship program
and i've enjoyed it i've made a lot of
great connections a lot of people
um both from the investment standpoint
operations as well as
you know academics that are looking to
sort of get into that or just go work
for a startup it's been great i think
they're recruiting for cohort 2 right
now so definitely recommend everybody to
do that um but yeah there's no better
time to get into this and you saw altos
you know
i guess it's no longer can you call it a
startup when it's a three billion dollar
you know
backing to the company but
it they've assembled a dream team
they're flush with the war chests
you know it's it's gonna be
a struggle but you know i don't think
anyone else is capable of doing it as
well as they can so
yeah i think it's going to be really
exciting to see yeah where they go with
it um i'd say i guess
i find all sort of question is what do
you think are the biggest unanswered
questions in the aging field at the
moment
um i'm going from a very senescence
centric world view
um it's just my worldview it's not the
right worldview but
cool if you if you share that worldview
so i think and that's what getting back
to those tissue mapping centers is you
know what where are these nestles what
are they what's around them you know
we're still building out good tools
to see and visualize senescent cells and
what are they doing to the cells around
them and so that's things where we're
utilizing emerging technologies like
mass imaging spatial genomics
i think you know
that we're using such primitive
techniques to identify snes and cells
and i really think we're building the
next generation tools right now whether
it be
spatial genomics or people like nate
vasyste who used to be at the buck
institute that's now at nia looking at
the secret tome and saskatchewan cells
that's their you know
building better center therapeutics
whether it's analytics and amorphics
cenestatics
you know whatever we want to call the
new drug class you know how do we do
precision center therapeutics whether
they're
more effective less toxicity
more cell type specificity and then you
can start putting them together in
combinations i think that's kind of the
future of the field that really excites
me
yeah no me too um i have some personal
interest in the sas competition for my
own like research project so yeah i'm
totally excited for the fields um so
yeah thank you so much for giving your
insights to the field today where can my
viewers go to hear more about your work
or to kind of follow more about you
uh
i'm
available by email i think you can find
me online my twitter profile is magnus
i love to chat about science i love bad
puns
um you got memes that's great
so
but yeah just find me and engage with me
and you know send me a link that you
think is cool i'll definitely read it
awesome yeah so thank you again for
coming on today um best of luck for your
research avenues um i'm sure we'll
probably hopefully meet some point in
person given our overlapping interests
um so yeah thank you again
thanks for having me
so i hope you've learned something in
this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you